we went to South Africa on a trip and
you know there's Nanny Mania going on
there do you still own the show The
Nanny right you own it I'm one of these
you're the producer and I are yeah but
we have a piece of the action have you
gotten to the syndication level yet no
that's gonna be the big payoff that's my
Mantra man yeah
a little you know overwhelmed and then I
just say syndication and it calms me
right how many years has the nanny been
on now three we're in our third season
and you know two more years and you're
there tonight and we slaughtered
everybody
yeah we crushed them really we spanked
them no kidding did you oh yeah yeah by
many many many rating points and shares
so you're very aware of the radio we
always do my father I'm sure is already
down in Florida booking bets like what
is your rating compared to like a
Melrose Place I think that they got like
a 19 or something and we got a 21 oh no
they dropped down maybe it was something
like an eight really Sharon we had a 21
chance
[Music]
foreign